where is he
there he is
grandpa crocodile loves you too
yeah this one's giving us all the feels
bindy irwin sharing a super special
moment on the gram you see him
is he over here
her daughter grace lights up after
spotting pics of bindi's late dad steve
irwin it's so special for for us getting
ready for the next generation of
wildlife warrior well one year later
this wildlife warrior is on the move all
over the erwin's family australia zoo
that's where bindi captured this
adorable moment grace recognizing the
crocodile hunter oh and bindi's nickname
for her dad is all sorts of adorable
grandpa crocodile and he's in his
construction hat
yeah
yeah
you love grandpa crocodile
yeah
yeah the one-year-old is obsessed with
pointing at pictures of grandpa
crocodile
love
love
good girl
love for grandpa crocodile
where is he
there he is
[Music]
hi
bindi caps off the moment with a sweet
message
hi grandpa crocodile
yeah good girl
i love you sweetheart
grandpa crocodile loves you too
the 24 year old sets the scene in the
instant caption writing we have a little
construction going on to make our
tasmanian devil habitat even more
beautiful grace's favorite part visiting
grandpa crocodile all the love
steve irwin died in 2006 when bindi was
just 8 years old but the families made
sure to carry on his passion for animals
including with little grace bindi
documents all her wildlife adventures on
insta
[Music]
she is just the light of our lives and
back in january bindi opened up to et
about the special role the family's zoo
plays in her daughter's life it's so
nice for us because we live and work
right here at australia zoo which is our
beautiful wildlife sanctuary so grace is
just always with me no matter what
whether we're at the australia zoo
wildlife hospital or in the middle of a
management meeting she is always with me
and i i feel incredibly lucky that we
get to do that i feel so lucky that she
can be part of every day of my life and
and watching her
soak in the world around her has been
truly magical
[Music]